the reason why I love what musk did I
love what Spotify did I love what Rumble
did what musk did with Twitter scared
the crap out of everybody because they
were always United together with Jack
Dorsey and all of them the moment they
lost Twitter with musk they all had to
check themselves the moment musk brought
Twitter back on Facebook and all those
guys brought Trump back on right so
Spotify the moment Spotify did in
silence uh Joe Rogan they realized oh
there's another place they can go
take their podcast with right so we
could take a loss even though all those
guys starts I'm gonna take my songs off
I'm never gonna sell here numbers okay
no problem Spotify said yeah we don't
care we're going to be fine yeah Joan
Baez oh my God Joan Baez is leaving
Spotify that's right that's right hell
am I going to listen and even even
Rumble you know what Rumble is doing
right now Rumble is kind of getting
YouTube to realize there's a second
option